uh well let's take you to the press uh
preview then and a first look at what is
on the front pages before they arrive in
the next half hour we'll be seeing
what's making the headlines with
broadcaster and former government
minister anna subri and pr consultant
alex dean so let's have a look at what
is on some of those front pages uh one
keeps calm and carries on that's the
front page on the metro after the queen
tests positive for covid19
the telegraph says she's determined to
carry on working despite the diagnosis
the mirror too going with that same line
she carries on
and that says the male is an example to
us or queens kovid example to us all
well the sun uh goes with uh a slightly
inaccurate pun actually h r h to
w f h
as her majesty vows to work on
and the eye has the same story and
reports multiple other cases have been
identified in the windsor castle
outbreak uh the castle outbreak's also
the front of the express
and the guardian has news that
last-ditch efforts to avert a russian
invasion of ukraine are taking place
those led by president macron of france
uh the ft staying with that same story
leading on the announcement that 30 000
russian troops will stay in belarus in
indefinitely adding uh to those western
fears of an invasion
and meanwhile the times that goes on
tomorrow's lifting of final coverage
restrictions in england highlighting
what it calls the pride of boris johnson
in the move
the star leads on forecasts of more wet
weather with four more storms that set
to batter britain amidst flood warnings
tonight and there's a reminder that by
scanning the qr code you'll see on
screen during the program uh you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
papers while you watch us
uh well as i said we are joined uh
tonight by anna subri and alex dean so
let's go straight uh to uh our papers uh
good evening to you both thanks for
being with us um let's begin uh with the
metro i mean if there was a story that
could knock ukraine uh off the front
pages it is this and the papers really
have uh had to make their choices uh
tonight
uh the queen has covered says the metro
one keeps calm and carries on and this
real emphasis on the fact that the queen
is supposed to be continuing light
duties but also an interesting point uh
anna subrie i wonder what you make of
this that the palace now getting in
front of this news and bringing it to us
rather than uh waiting a day or two
yes um and rightly so
look the reason why of course the
majesty can continue working from home
and stay calm is because
mercifully she's triple vaccinated and
she has a very mild form of covid and of
course there are unfortunately people
even those who be triple backs who could
have a nastier form of it but as i say
mercifully our queen has got the mild
form so that's why she's able to carry
on so i slightly peeved if you like by
the the
implication in the mail that somehow the
queen was carrying on in a way that the
british people
aren't carrying on which is a nonsense
of course
and actually funny funnily enough
honestly it's interesting that is what
they have
i'm so sorry we lost you slightly there
so i was jumping in to say that is
you're right that the example to us all
which uh has been uh some on some of the
papers i think it was the daily mail had
that the example to us all does suggest
yes that the queen leading that example
by working from home when of course we
have all been working from home haven't
we
yes
exactly and there are lots of people who
would like not to be working from home
lots of people who are fed up being in
isolation want to get back to work so i
think we just have to put this all into
proportion the most important thing is
as i was trying to say and forgive me
for the line was that you know when we
heard she got clovia a lot of us would
be really worried because she's 95 she's
an extraordinary woman and now to know
that she has this mild form
is hugely reassuring and of course we
all wish her a speedy recovery she is
however incredible there is no debate
about that
um on the sun also they are saying yeah
hrh to w f h to work from home uh the
eye also queen still at work uh with
covid uh alex dean it's interesting how
uh the queen's health
treads this interesting line between a
private matter and that is what the
palace uh has often said about it and of
course it is a matter of great uh public
interest uh because she is the head of
state as well so the palace having to
tread that line
yeah that's right and i i thought they'd
handled this story very well and they've
um as you're saying get i got out in
front of it and brief people about it
god bless our queen and a lifetime of
public service and now she has
coronavirus um i thought that there the
parallels are quite interesting about
the things that she's seen in her
lifetime we remember that the royal
family um when they were bombed during
the blitz that they could finally look
the west end
in the eye and now have millions of her
subjects having had coronavirus the
queen
has got it too we wish her a speedy
recovery of course but i i immerse
slightly from what you were both saying
i think she is an example to us all in
her fortitude and in her public service
at 95 i think that's an example for
everybody
well certainly we had a royal uh
commentator coming on just uh earlier uh
this evening saying exactly that that
the way she behaved over uh the funeral
of her husband uh the fact that she was
the first to say that one ought to go
get a vaccine think of everybody else
that she had been a role model
absolutely indeed um interestingly the
metro bringing up the difficult week
that she's had already after prince
andrew agreed a 12 million pound deal to
head off a sex abuse trial and the met
says it's probing prince charles's
charity for uh cash for honors uh
scandal i mean anna subi she's she's
really you know light light duties might
be what it's called but she's got a lot
on her plate at the moment hasn't she
yes she has and of course the settlement
of prince andrew's claim
um will have been a huge relief to her
but she's had a difficult time but she's
coming through it in her platinum
jubilee year
and rightly so
i think can i just say i think one of
the things that of course this is
going to cause an interest in parliament
if it's right that the government's
going to lift all its uh covert
restrictions as is being widely reported
there will be people who will be
slightly concerned about that remember
over 50 000 people are still catching
copied the number of people dying from
it is still high mercifully not as much
as it was and so we i think that people
will be rightly and members of
parliament of course returning next week
asking whether we are doing this in the
right way and in particular are we doing
it because it's the right thing to do
and it's what science tells us to do or
are we doing it because it's part of
saving boris johnson who um is in eve
in great difficulty uh and this is all
part of his plan to get him out of
partygate when of course he broke the
very rules that our queen kept to uh and
it's a way of keeping him uh in power
but anyway there she is certainly
certainly
certainly a lot of
resonances between those two stories and
in fact the daily telegraph obviously
with the photograph of her majesty on
the front page then just below free
tests to be kept for over 80s as plans
are made to learn to live with the virus
so there we go perhaps boris johnson
responding to some of those fears that
actually if you are over 80 uh you will
still be able to get hold of free covert
tests but
i mean alex dean does that matter if
those around you are not able to get
hold of those tests
well i think it does because what we've
seen from the data are the groups at
most risk from coronavirus and whilst of
course statistically um
you can't write off the risk uh to any
to any age group from coronavirus it's
overwhelmingly felt most of all amongst
those who are 80 plus so i do think
there is sense in that and i think
there's sense too in the government's
position that we've got to learn to live
with kovid i think countries that have
adopted a zero coverage strategy either
have a great more great deal more of a
command and control centralized economy
under which we might not wish to live in
the first place like china or have a had
a zero-covered policy and then reversed
it uh jacinta ardern in new zealand
admitted that they were wrong to try to
pursue a zero covered position in the
end i think it's a statement of the
obvious that we've got to learn to live
with coronavirus i'm glad we're doing it
but i'm glad too that we're thinking
about those who are vulnerable and
trying to find ways uh to make sure that
life can be easier for them and free
tests for the over 80s is one aspect of
it well it is one aspect but of course
the over 80s if they catch it are going
to catch it from people who are younger
and those people if they're not
regularly testing
because they have to pay for their tests
that the incentive might not be uh as
high i wonder anna subari i saw you uh
shaking your head at one point do you
agree do you think it is time we learn
to live uh with covid and what does that
even mean
well exactly and most people are
actually learning to live with it and
have been for almost two years now
actually and struggling uh as a result
of the restrictions there's no debate
about that but it was the worst thing it
was the best thing rather to do and we
needed to do it remember we have one of
the worst death rates in the world we
certainly have the just second worst
death rate uh in europe second only to
italy so you know to see on the front
page of the times that johnson is
somehow proud
of our covid um the way he's handled it
is i find absolutely outrageous he
should be hanging his head in shame but
it's also interesting in the telegraph
i've got alex just just very quickly
because we are almost out of time just
come back on that very quickly
absolutely much of central and eastern
europe have worse death rates in the uk
we are second only to
it in the death and it's interesting on
the front page of the telegraph
we're losing your line a little bit so
i'm going to quickly go to alex uh
before we have a break just for 10
seconds on that your response to what
anna was saying there
well it's hard to tell what she was
saying other than that if she was saying
that italy's the only country in europe
that's got the worst death rate in the
uk it's not true okay
let us come back after the break i'm so
sorry we are all out of time there with
anna and alex um and alex we will be
back uh for the rest of the press a
preview coming up the metro reporting
that russian president vladimir putin
has instructed commanders to invade
ukraine with the situation on a knife
edge that and plenty more after the
break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now i'm afraid we've
lost anna subri uh but we do have alex
dean pr consultant still with us so alex
i'm afraid you're gonna have to battle
on on your own for a bit until we get
anna's subaru back um let's begin
actually funny enough we were ju we were
just talking before uh before we went
into the break about death rates death
rates
between countries uh of covid are
notoriously hard to compare because
obviously everyone uh tests and
everybody counts them differently i
think on current death rates i'm trying
to work out what anna was saying whether
she was saying uh a total death rate of
covert but current death rates uh it
seems that she is right that italy is
above the usa is above the uk but of
course in total death rates that's a
totally different matter so um
let us forgive me but she she was made
to i mean on absolute terms of course
the uk has a higher death count in italy
so she can't submit that what she meant
was as a percentage of the population
and it feels unfair to me without her
but given that you've asked me you've
invited me to um yeah bulgaria bosnia
hungary i've tweeted this georgia
croatia czechia slovakia romania these
are all european countries worth
destroying the uk armenia moldova latvia
belgium um you know these are italy
greece
there are many many countries in europe
that have worse death rates than the uk
and i fear that anna is using some very
old talking points
okay very interesting right let's we'll
let anna come back to you when she
returns but for now we're going to move
on to the crisis in ukraine and the
front of the ft
uh belarus says russian troops will stay
as west seeks ukraine talks it is not
looking good alex is it belarus is of
course europe's last dictatorship and it
is a country that um has seen
significant violations of human rights
significant
attacks on pro-democracy movements in
its country and here is the latest
demonstration of its continuing uh
malign government and its alliance uh
with russia of course as a sovereign
country it's entitled if it wishes to to
invite the russians into its country to
write their military forces in but i
must say having them perched on at the
edge of their country threatening
countries to the west of them hardly
does any good for belarus prospects of
rehabilitation in the international
community and to take its place in the
community of nations i hope they realize
quite how bad this makes them look in
the eyes of everyone the way that this
is threatening to the baltic states the
way it's threatening to ukraine itself i
think is terrible uh for the region and
it's really bad for belarus i really
hope they think again